welcome to this video new part on the
series on tactics and calculation yeah
this is mostly about one single position
that I wanted to show you and it's from
one of my games and in fact it's from
the game that I considered to be the
nicest finish that I have a played in a
game of chess at least in tournament
chess not sure about all the Blitz games
but it's definitely the nicest that I
ever got in tournament chess
the position is I'd move 18 so
relatively early in the game and the
situation that is so crazy that I find
it's a little bit bit weird just to put
the position on the board without
showing where we could how we got there
because it looks very strange I just
want to go briefly through the game very
briefly to so that you know I'm where
this how this how this come to this game
on the board this is plate 2010 a couple
of years ago against an international
master from the Netherland Winston Road
who is so not really a bad opponent but
he really had an off day as we see in
the opening yeah we have this kind of
ratty flank opening Quincy - yeah here
Knight b6 is the normal way to play
however he went with b5 which is
interesting it's not bad I really didn't
know the move in this precise position I
decided to try to yeah fight this
head-on with b3 he took and I took on c6
looka p8 not much else
maybe yeah and here he I'm not quite
sure what he what he missed there but
here he played the movie 6 and after
that black is already in huge trouble
because of the very simple reply and
rook takes I can just take him and after
that he really does not have any any
good compensation maybe he was
thinking about Bishop c5 here but this
just failed to route d7 I am Not sure
but after that he's in very very big
trouble already
instead here move like the Bishop d7
needs to very okay play for black he
certainly hasn't okay but we can just
play a six later everyone's okay he went
here and I could just take and I did
take Knight to f6 93 and yeah here he
definitely should try to develop Bishop
c5 or something but he went before and
after Knight b5 I think he's already
lost was 97 96 ideas are too much it was
really not a good game by black it's
it's really most about the finish which
is very nice Bishop c5 yeah here I have
the check King f8 and tier White has a
choice I can just play rook c7 which is
the simplest move in a way as it after
the takes takes leads to a completely
overwhelming position with an extra pawn
even but I was attracted to Knight takes
f7 because it just it's just so forceful
to take them the big point is of course
he cannot take it all because I take the
bishop using the rook on the seventh so
he has to play Queenie Sam there's
really no other logical move room that
he can play now if I take the room he
takes a seven and this is not clear at
all well this is all of a sudden my
knight is strapped I have given up rook
on a seven so this is not not really
great and my idea was to play Luke c7
the point is that now after King takes
this is what he played and probably
should play I have a nice move and now
he needs to yeah he needs to take a walk
with the King King g6 if he goes back I
just take this red check and win easily
this is how I ended up with the King in
the open yeah here I have a choice I can
play d4 or bishop before and I couldn't
really calculate it
till the end I went to shoot before d4
is also very strong and now he went to
h5 this makes it as difficult as
possible the point is that if he takes I
have default check yeah King to the side
and then I just I can just take on on
seats and c5 and to have a fantastic
position yeah like really is without a
defense here what what should he play
and thus his King one h5 is just just
enormous the bad piece and he can he
cannot move really the few takes for
example Queen takes it's a disaster
there's ideas like g4 yeah or h4 g4 with
made the King here on the south side
it's not it's not going to survive he
went to age 5 and now here I saw I saw
the finish of the game but let's look at
exactly here this is the position where
you can treat this as a puzzle and find
the strongest continuations there is
more than one way for white to win this
but there is one way that is the
quickest way and it's also my father the
most attractive way the the nicest way
to win so if you want you should pause
the video and think about this how does
wide wynia in the nicest possible way
and black it absolutely has no defense
the computer is giving like a maid in 20
or something if in some line ok this I
did not see I saw the the game
continuation was this the most important
yeah let's let you have a look now
yeah okay I'm going to show show it now
yeah I was very delighted to being able
to play the move h3 I absolutely
absolutely loved it the Queen is hanging
and white can react by this
innocent-looking little corn and after
that
why does in fact really completely
winning my opponent much to his credit
was nice enough to capture the Queen now
and let the the mate play out on the
board and he has no defense anyway I
mean if you give it to an engine it
gives Knight takes e4 as the relatively
toughest which I briefly looked at of
course as well but it's it's this is
relatively easy to see why this wins
when it goes g4 check King edge for that
mate nice little checkmate and after
let's say here white can just jack take
on e4 and win the house this is
checkmate made after this you can you
can do something like that if you don't
find anything else there might be
something something even even better but
this is what I was I was seeing after
this you can take here threatening night
f7 double check and mate so black has
has no move now
yeah he captured the Queen and now this
is a mate in and I think five moves
I'm counting counting correctly can for
check and first the easiest lines this
is checkmate mate double check checkmate
this is we had seen before so he took H
takes check for double check he has to
take now f3 check only one reply King g3
rook III check f4j pawn move check
kingi one and here white has the choice
between rook h1 and Bishop b3 to be
honest I didn't see before that Bishop
e3 is also made maybe I should play
Bishop b3 it's a matter I had seen rook
h1 beforehand and I played this check me
quickly and I liked it and this is the
most attractive mate I ever got got on
the board in a game of chess the King on
on g1 the black King on g1 getting
melted after 24 moves and this is out of
out of this type of opening this is
really really unusual it might happen in
the King's gambit or something like that
but not in a flank opening yeah I hope
you you like this it's a it's a really a
super super nice finish to a game and I
gave much much credit to my opponent
that shot he let me play it out on
chapman over the board he didn't it
didn't resign beforehand which was very
nice and this was very nice very young
the service was really great this played
out on the board yeah I hope you enjoyed
enjoyed this this little game and the
position to solve and yeah I mean back
soon with more nice technical games and
samples thanks for watching